une perte donc du contrat du siècle et
une crise diplomatique entre les états
unis et la france qui s'en est suivi au
coeur aussi de plusieurs discussions en
coulisses anthony blinken à paris pour
tenter de recoller les morceaux
entretien mi-octobre entre emmanuel
macron et joe biden on en parle tout de
suite avec vous régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france ce soir on apprend
donc par la bouche de jean yves le drian
que l'ambassadeur de france et rapatrié
en australie qu'il y aura bien une
rencontre une autre entre emmanuel
macron et joe biden cette fois ci on
devrait certainement ça y est on passe
l'épongé malgré quelques nuances en
termes de communication fin de
l'histoire quasiment alors pas fin de
l'histoire je pense il faut analyser
d'abord
quelques 10 les deux parties on sent
qu'il ya plus une volonté américaine de
dire oui oh bah voilà la crise est
derrière nous
ping anthony blinken et jean yves le
drian se sont se sont rencontrés ont
discuté emmanuel macron à a eu s'est
entretenu avec le président américain
tout ça montre quand même qui reste
quand même un profond malaise du côté
français on entend jean yves le drian
dire qu'il faudra des actes pour que
pour mettre cette crise derrière
derrière la relation franco américaine
je rappelle quand même que les propos de
jean yves le drian il faut vraiment
l'air située au moment de la rupture du
contrat jean yves le drian a parlé de
coups dans le dos d'actes brutale qui
rappelle ce que nous faisait monsieur
trompe ce sont les mots de jean yves le
drian à l'époque donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire bien ça veut dire que le
ministre des affaires étrangères
français considèrent à considérer est à
mon avis considère toujours que la
politique étrangère américaine n'a pas
fondamentalement changé depuis l'époque
trump et moi j'ajouterais qu'au moins à
l'époque de donald trump il y avait une
mérites d'une certaine franchise la
colère voilà tandis que là on bah oui
joe biden est arrivé ça y est c'est le
sauveur tout va bien la relation avec
les alliés va être réparée on va arrêter
de se faire marcher sur les pieds et on
se rend compte que il ya évidemment le
plus grave cette crise des sous marins
mais n'oublions pas qu'il ya le contrat
d'armement qui nous est passé sous le
nez avec la suisse un autre contrat
navigation aussi avec l'allemagne et que
finalement on a l'impression que les
américains estiment qu'ils peuvent faire
des coups dans le dos comme ça aux
français après viennent rappeler
effectivement que il avait peut-être
sous-estimé la force de cette relation
franco-américaine qu'il fallait qu'ils
entretiennent mais ce qu'a fait monsieur
blinken finalement il a fait et où il
est il a été parfaitement dans son rôle
le rôle du francophone francophile qui a
vécu à paris qui considère la france
comme sa deuxième patrie on l'a entendu
hier soir sur france 2 on n'a pas
entendu jean yves le drian lui dire la
même chose que ce qui lui avait dit en
juin bienvenue chez toi en parlant de la
france là la france est quand même très
gêné il y a eu une une véritable voilà
je pense que je pense que la france s'y
attendait pas enfin elle s'y attendait
pas no il est clair que il y a eu tout
l'été des doutes des atermoiements on
avait eu des infos comme quoi le contrat
que man comme quoi il y avait de l'eau
dans le gaz autour du contrat maintenant
une rupture aussi aussi brutale sur un
repositionnement stratégique des états
unis dans la zone inde au passage au
pacifique face à la chine je pense pas
que on avait anticipé que ça serait donc
jean ce brillant dit vrai au sénat
aujourd'hui des trahisons mensonges
il est de bonne foi selon vous je pense
qu'il est de bonne foi mais y avait
quand même il aurait dû regarder ses
arrières parce que il y avait des signes
déjà cet été qu'il y avait ce possible
repositionnement stratégique et ce
repositionnement stratégique il va dans
tout un ensemble qui parle justement de
l'évacuation du retrait des américains
d'afghanistan jusqu'à ce nouveau focus
militaires cette fois sur la chine
jusqu'à imposer des sous marins
nucléaires
nucléaire à l'australie pour qui vous
savez en australie nucléaire c'est un
gros mot est spécifiquement nous avions
établi ce contrat pour que les
australiens puissent bénéficier de
sous-marin ssn à classique avec toute la
technologie barracuda que nous avons
expérimenté mais qui ne portait pas la
propulsion nucléaire c'est ce que les
australiens avaient demandé et là les
américains en europe impose un nouveau
contrat en plus un contrat qui arrivera
en 2040 à leur pleine hotte devait
prendre forme en 2030 donc en réalité on
se trouve dans un la france a été laissé
pour compte de 7-2 ce repositionnement
stratégique
c'est toujours america first
america first on le sait c'était grand
slogan de donald trump on s'aperçoit que
finalement la politique étrangère de joe
biden n'a pas fondamentalement changé et
les états unis d'une certaine façon
prennent leurs alliés à la légère au
point qu'aujourd'hui l'europe entière se
commence à ceux à se positionner sur
l'idée de l'europe de défense de la
défense qui commencent à revenir
aujourd'hui les parlementaires sont à
mbia n'a donc en slovénie il ya ils ont
commencé à travailler travailler sur une
forme d'autonomie stratégique de
l'europe immédiatement critiqué
d'ailleurs par jens stoltenberg
tout à fait donc le secrétaire de l'otan
qui voit et qui voit effectivement une
velléité de concurrence à l'organisation
du traité de l'atlantique et que
l'on se rend compte que là il ya moins
comment un repositionnement une prise de
conscience peut-être des européens que
dans l'avenir il importe quand même que
l'europe puisse disposer d'une force si
elle veut marquer des points si elle
veut par rapport à la turquie par
rapport à tout un tas d'ensemble qui
commencent à émerger
ce retrait des américains il n'est pas
simplement le retrait des américains en
afghanistan il s'est fait aussi au
moyen-orient au moyen-orient des
puissances ont émergé en afrique
également on voit la russie qui est à
l'offensive or on voit la chine qui est
à l'offensive et la france et l'europe
s'interroge dans dix ans nous est-ce
qu'on va être finalement
systématiquement à la remorque de l'otan
et la france en particulier se pose la
question de rester de façon
inconditionnelle l'allié des etats-unis
quand on voit comment les états unis à j
vis-à-vis de nous je